welcome to this video this is Round
seven coverage for the sink filled cup
let's see what happened in round seven
um we start with a somewhat non exciting
game to pile of geary and this will be
one of the quickest yeah i've used on
the game ever they're here on the
channel because tapado for some reason
went for this slide and he mean this is
Jack trainee Queens iam um well he has
lost the last two games and this is
maybe an explanation why he chooses this
somewhat non liner and it's a very very
safe line and with them wear white
basically can never lose if it's not
totally brain dead and well he's also
not going to win much um it's a super
save line and we see that Yuri equalized
with no problem one thing is that f65
set up that is nowadays the set up that
is known to be completely equal for
black in the 80s they sometimes played
it differently and then why'd sometimes
had something good here we just see I
mean we have got trade straight trades
and absolutely nothing is happening ya
know white can claim that his night is a
slightly more active piece than this
bishop but well in fact it's simply
nothing going on sanity check shuffled
around a little bit and agreed to draw
yet so a bit of a non game and it's an
entire Liam the white players choice to
go for this 584 I mean Gary as he said
he was ready for green for the fight
goes before we have a Greenfeld but he
fears if I was just exceedingly boring
which is after say something that I have
played in the past if I was some paired
against the strong opponent and I felt
that the jaw is okay and I really
don't want to play because of whatever
circumstances and this line is perfect
and I said you can hardly lose it's very
difficult to lose this this this line
with white um okay anyway that was very
unexcited Khurrana Rashi de Graaff that
was next game on my list and they had a
Bishop b5 the Syrian again I think it's
interesting that Russia also goes from
97 TM um that moose seems to be very
much in fashion the old main line of
Bishop d7 has not seen that much anymore
it seems that this is farm one or VOC
nowadays yeah and we get this is quite
funny we get the position that looks a
lot like a real or perceived yeah pretty
pretty reminiscent of some some chicken
or some brea brea more than a children
especially after before here that's a
good move here by koala that is a
typical device designed to fix that pawn
on d5 and gaining some space but MBL is
playing that nicely plays Bishop d8 and
he's got this at the end mind you know
trying to activate that Bishop the game
of that was the wrong button the game
already has some have to say
unfortunately it only has one one key
moment this is here after night eh fire
white had spent some tempe to fix the
queenside after night h5 here white had
an interesting opportunity that he did
not take and it's not clear if it was
promising white an advantage but that
was the moment where the game could have
turned really crazy white ultimately
took on the eight after which not not
much was happening night xe5 however is
an interesting interesting move young
looking at that looking at that night
um yeah best is Bishop takes 35 now for
black and tween h5 Bishop f6 it's pretty
clear that this this kind of position is
giving black very good compensation that
Bishop on f6 is just very strong while
the night is not doing that much and
especially that porn is under fire their
form after we should have six knight c6
is more interesting and now Bishop c3
1917 age 85 is the line that after the
game kawada showed in them I'm in the
Pinder in the interview he had seen this
but wasn't sure about the consequences
like g6 and he showed it up sugar up to
here like this Tigs and he said he
couldn't really figure out what was
going on which is understandable it is
probably entirely unclear why it has got
a rook for two pieces but why it has a
ton of pawns and the whole situation is
completely completely a messy it's very
difficult to get to grips to that that
was however than the one moment in the
game where something exciting who have
happened after Bishop d8 loop 289 age 46
I think I'm black can be satisfied with
this position I have played the
structure I'm quite a bit with black in
my somewhat outdated she go in line and
here a couple of things are okay from
the black point of view the trade of the
dark squared bishop is definitely
something that black does not mind often
that bishop is kind of passive
seven or g7 or somewhere like that also
trading one pound of minor pieces is
good black hands less space and also the
a file is open this is in fact kind of a
double-edged thing sometimes they file
open it's favoring wide but I think here
my black doesn't have any problem and in
fact here he has chances to use the AFR
to trade off the heavy pieces and if
then if the queens and rooks are going
of the board not much is happening yeah
he's playing that ok now regrouping that
Bishop to d7 and now we see that the
rooks are traded on the a phallus what I
meant now this position would have been
more interesting for what if the AFI
would have been closed because then
white might have been able to do
something on the King side where the FR
and all Queen side is closed but here he
cannot abandon the a file and can hand
it to black so this is kind of a
chopping block for those pieces yeah so
that is traded and here they agreed to a
draw yes there's really not much going
on even though I have to say that I have
one that kind of endgame quite quite
often in rapid and blitz chess ok this
is not rapid not Blitzen the players are
much stronger than your usual opponent
only on the ICC but I mean you can try
you can try something with black if you
go for a five and maybe put some
pressure on those pawns I'm not saying
that black is bad as just a drug it
wasn't completely necessary to agree to
a row or idea they could have they could
have continued a bit okay not not very
exciting next game is a bit more
interesting i was fish island with white
vs wesley soul ok that's all we had
gotta move in again
not the end gave this time and now we
she took on c6 yeah this is this type of
structure to be honest is or has always
been a bit of a mystery to me I
sometimes have it myself it's black I'm
usually with the bishop 1e7 because I
don't play the bull and I play the
classical available with a six classical
is also wrong I play a 69 f6 Bishop e7
de traditional line let's say the
classical is something different and
sometimes they change on c6 as well and
it can lead to the same kind of a game
and I really never understood what
White's ideas here um the only person
will is course with that with widest
practice garden and i'm going to show
you exactly what i'm talking about that
look at the structure that they get in
the game like this um i always wonder
what what what what the plan is here for
white with black i'm pretty sure what I
want to do I want to put the night
submit on d4 and while I already have
the two bishops oh I don't need to worry
about the future anyway in that regard
and what is wise idea i mean d 4 is
difficult to play and the only idea that
i can see that from that makes some
sense to me is to try to play F for ya
to open up the position on the King side
but it's not so easy to do and quite
often if use if you imagine a night on e
cigs on g6 it's not even even remotely
possible um I really don't know I really
don't know I don't know what white is to
it I mean it's obviously very solid and
I mean if you place I don't know we
should be three or something and black
trades and so on that's very not much
going on it's I'll just solid but it's
it doesn't feel like very threatening to
black and in fact in this game and
played some strange move so
with 90 + b2 I don't know it looks
strange really look strange and
especially considering i mean what
you're white right you want to to get
some kind of thing going and this is
already feels like like it's totally
fine um yeah a lot went for default and
sacrifice a pawn they're trying to get
compensation against the weekend Queen
side it's I'm not sure I mean white has
a little bit of compensation but black
still a he enjoys the bishop path and he
doesn't have any any really bad piece
and at best can be can be a vague
compensation in 396 our counter checking
that Bishop went back back to 87 and ce4
yeah that's a good idea that limits the
Black Knight now c5 that's a good move
it it's active it looks at those clears
and it limits that v7 night I think here
I mean I'm not sure full compensation
I'm not sure but I think it's clear that
it's definitely difficult for black to
make headway in this position as why
this really active that looks or very
normal and nights before yeah yeah I'm
not already had the idea that we will
see in their game and well why did he
give up the Seafarer porn that happened
because he wanted to play this night x
e6 that's an interesting interesting
choice white after Bishop if before
decided to take on yourself and give up
the Queen well okay and this is in fact
interesting takes takes Bishop to Queen
takes was also possible yeah something
like that it's a very very comparable to
them to the actual game just slightly
different piece placement now I think
the same evaluation is is probably
justified as in the game why it has
chances to hold you to this fortress
options we will see in the in the game
how it how it can be and can be played
with those photos ideas and I did it is
it is not very attractive to play but
white certainly has his chances to to
draw this interesting that are not so
quickly got into this kind of I mean
this is a very unattractive prospect
because white can never ever win now you
can only draw if things fall into place
or or lose yeah Bishop takes was played
rook takes bishop f7 that's all very
logical f5 there was a necessary move
because white threatened to play night
before I possibly night to c5 if he
would get that in night to see five then
its position would be rather good then
the night is protecting this and still
has active idea so f five is good Brooks
is 627 went back and drew key agent
ending this of all things and it's
important to understand that the
computers evaluation it's not very
reliable here of course I mean the
computer gives black a complete win and
of course black is better however the
computer is not CM or does not
understand the concept of a fortress
correct
even in the final position that we will
see shortly and the computer thinks that
black is winning even though this is not
the case yeah around here I remember
that koalas game was finished and he was
in the in the interview room and when
the interview was finished um he
actually asked Austin okay please give
us your opinion on the on the games that
are still running at he guessed that
this game my auntie I was whining and so
would end in a draw because he felt that
it would be very difficult to break a
fortress and we see the fraud fortress
shaping up rather quickly and nights you
for like to get through Teague's okay to
age three and we can go right to the
final position yeah that's right here we
see six black offer to draw yeah this is
what would happen Teague's Teague's now
sorry rook c5 is better sorry screw that
one up queen bee through you want this
pawn yeah and here this is this is a
typical thing that computers and hard
time to understand in fact stockfish is
not giving black a win but just a slight
edge which is a good sign so computers
have gotten a little bit better at least
at this because it is really a total
draw why can just put this book on c5
and stay yeah there's absolutely nothing
that I can do to to progress and it's a
very very easy positional draw with that
you can see five stopping or counter
play certainly a game where we can
question if Wesley had some chances
there after the the Queen
sacrifice by anand he definitely wasn't
a comfortable situation there but
playing it even more accurately to
really get a win out of it is a
different thing um I mean I did not
really have hours on hand to find
something so I had no success and but
also the the people who did the did the
commentary there they were really
skeptical about legs winning shot this
may be it is a draw after all I mean
it's not such a terrible situation for
whitey is rather well coordinated here
it is clear to draw but somewhat earlier
maybe at though usually those cell or
quite often those material imbalances um
they depend on the quality and
coordination of the piece and once
widest established that his he's okay to
draw okay that was the game on and so
they are not a great game by for vishy
but um it done yeah you can't can't have
the the great games all over time and he
really doesn't have a all together great
great tournament okay so up to the next
game so when X game cars in Greece oh
here we go yeah again Kozma is going for
the open Sicilian yeah this has netted
him a nice victory against the West a
soul but this time he switches to a
different line us Bishop e2 now and
actually impedes what what Allah did a
couple of runs early against mvl in that
game on the french player played knight
c6 and then d5 that was not what we
shook wanted to do here you went like
BDSM adjuster also the more normal night
placement in the
in the night off one reason is that term
oops I'm sorry white is already
signaling his intentions to to put an
idol of d5 with an add-on d7 you are
ready to capture that night quite
comfortably 95 in fact was played
castles castles bush antiques eg5 looks
aight ya see 498 Queen d2 b 6 years I've
gotta wear those couple of most of it
quicker because I want to look at this
particular position and talk about the
structure here the funny thing is that
in the in that event they have that
how's it called the confessional booth
or something ever they players can
during the game issue a quick statement
about that state of mind or what they
think about the position or whatever and
hear cars and I'm supposed to personally
I mean I didn't I didn't see that we
just watched that part but he was um
they say that that he went to that the
booth at he said that he doesn't like
his position at all um yep but then I
really want to know why he chose that
opening line in the first place because
um that's the whole point of the line I
mean if you play Knight to Queen d3 here
the only idea is 95 and to get exactly
that structure I mean this is
essentially what you aim for so if you
don't like it then why did you aim for
it in the first place that i found a bit
a bit strange and i meani account
obviously is aware that this is I mean
normal for that line if you go with you
play with Queen d3 that's the old idea
by FM geller back from the 60s and you
want that structure yeah if you don't
want it why I play Queen you three it's
a bit um
strange um so what is the point of this
pawn structure yeah what with the night
coming to d5 and then taking with the e
porn he now has created a for against
the form against three pawn majority on
the queenside and he'd likes to get
those pawns rolling yeah a 4 B 4 and so
on especially a nice would be to get in
like before a4 a5 to ultimately get to
that to that a pawn the real issue for
white in this some structure and in this
game in particular is that the night on
b3 is simply entirely wrong this
position if we just make a guess of some
some assumption some theoretical
question if if white would have this
knight on c3 instead of b3 I would
assume that he has a pretty decent
advantage yeah I mean nothing like
winning but it would be nice for why
because he quickly can play before a 4
and so on play on the queenside while
black scaled to play with f5 it's not
hitting that hard yet and this is in
fact what black ones to do black has
four against three as well of course we
it's not a porn down and he wants to set
his pawns there in motion sometimes with
the Jeep on sometimes not an idea is
also to put the bishop here activated
yeah and this is some belief to read
that whole structure is believed to be
around equal but it's still it's
sophisticated to play it's not easy so
on can be recommended for for both
players also on sometimes recommend this
kind of system to white players looking
for a more strategic way to better the
night off I think this is not a lot of
bad deal there are a couple of ways to
to to get to that structure car this is
just it's just one of them so with the
elders had a bit strange that he didn't
like his position at all because he went
for it very knowingly over here so he
clear that would have
a five yes black is trying to block on
the queenside and now night a 13 is
funny to put the night in the corner but
it does make some sense the night really
was bad there and maybe we can we can
envision a route like this for example
putting the knight on d5 or simply get
it over to the king aside some more like
this this oh that was wrong but you know
what I mean getting it over on the King
sign and there's also a second idea and
we will see that very soon black played
g6 and now he comes the second idea
before it's not a very typical move
playing that without any further
preparation with a three but it has a
concrete idea of black takes which looks
nice due to Blackie gaining that square
white those nights e2 and Knight b6 to
see form is rather uncomfortable and
therefore my g7 like just keeps the
position on the queenside which should
be three looking at that f five square a
form interesting yeah now Carson and
decided to take that pawn no I'm sorry
if I know if that would be one first
yeah I'm sorry you know II former GRU
shocked that that is the moment where he
took that took that pond yeah I mean
black certainly is okay here we may
guess pretty okay pieces Bishop can come
to f6 Knight to f5 oh okay um however he
might white might win a porn which
happened here this what what Carlton
played however black clearly has um yeah
fine compensation
and it's difficult I mean at the moment
black gets a pawn back but white will
will also win the e4 pawn check this now
yeah I have a black get set quick
counter play against a upon its am
really not that much happening like
activates a bit wide activates a bit or
or normal and now black finally got the
pawn back and this is a very Jewish
position however what cards now did is
somewhat uncharacteristic of him 11 huge
quality that he has is that he's
normally playing very objective sober
moves yeah it's not really trying to do
some things that the position does not
allow and this is different to some
other players if you compare this not
the one to say anything bad David some
some people some guy like to parlor for
exam he's so aggressive that sometimes
he will just overdo it and he knows it
yeah he really but he wins lots of games
with that aggressive style but he also
loses some where he just plays it a
little bit too hard and the next move is
something that it's difficult to explain
cause Benji form I mean what's he really
afraid of night f5 or I don't know the
problem is I mean black girls bishop d
for now and Bishop c5 and this is really
not good I mean I mean promise yeah this
is always now pressurized and night x is
six the right moment is not helping you
now that that porn on c6 is completely
um um completely detached from the rest
of your game the rest of your forces
from here on black is better really
better and on top of it
he also didn't have much time we had
those trades takes on c6 and now like
really one that pawn yeah and from here
on it's no fun to what absolutely not
and then we can continue a couple of
moves now the child control was was
finished the next critical moment is
here when he went age five that's a
debatable decision yeah as a defender
you quite usually want to trade pawns
we'd use the pawn count and therefore
maybe h5 makes some sense because black
go take it you cannot go g5 I mean I
cannot go here because it all of the
sudden would regroup very nicely so leg
will take and the question is really did
that help wide I mean that pawn there's
a potential weakness and I don't really
see a great way forward what I do know
is that we shook now played a very
patient good technical game he very
slowly check yeah mate made progress you
don't have to you don't want to rush
things just play put it forward slowly
the strap advantage we are all the time
in the world check a couple of chicks
check yeah here now is a critical moment
we shop now played rook is six and
engines give Kings you three is stronger
essentially winning camp it is it really
winning yeah I was own I'm always
checking um what Grandmaster Ramirez has
to say on chessbase commie there's a
quick annotation right after the round
using sometimes statements of the
players and so on
is always very helpful because I don't
watch the broadcast the whole time at
his part of the commentators and done or
the team at the place so he gets to know
some things that you can only know if
you have watched the broadcast so it's
useful to know for my for my videos and
he says that on Kings III is given as
winning by the engines but he's not
entirely sure if it really really does
win um yeah I understand that the thing
is that I mean if Y takes and now just
just shuffles here are you really
winning it's it's it's not clear to me
really I have to agree it's not clear to
me there are some fortress types of
positions here even if the computer give
Zach the advantage it's not entirely
sure that this is really the case
because sometimes they don't understand
the fortress concept that what yes sir
what is in some trouble it doesn't look
good whatever but how to really go ahead
I mean from d3 the night has a ton of
squares where it can jump and then jump
back and how are you going to win it if
you go over to h5 that will probably a
yeah not keep the pawn on d4 it is not
entirely sure what we shook did rook is
6 however after f4 we should have six
pigs pigs yeah and now the next move I
am and this is a clear mistake it seems
bye-bye Carlton we are dealing or we are
talking about a situation where he was
down on time basically playing on the on
the increment that starts with move 60
and he played them overnight f2 after
that he is definitely lost it seems that
kinky too according to the computers
would still hold interestingly enough um
how exactly how exactly shall this hold
let's have a look King d5 trying to go
in there now we can go back here
this is a problem so up to here and now
if King inform we have giant c5 check
that's them for one point let's now this
pawn to attack which is not there in
this situation with only seven here we
really have a drawn here King m3 yeah
and now it is a draw something like this
there is absolutely no way forward it
seems that kingly to was indeed a draw
not one hundred percent sure but it
seems to seems to be a draw it is
however clear that night f2 just loose
there should be seven now this is a
Duke's one why exactly the problem is if
white now what did he do exactly played
Nagi forward let's say why does that
then we're going to go here and now your
king can all move so you have to move
here night again King cannot move have
to move the night and now something like
we should be six probably deserve this
win chat here back we go back visit
Bishop c7 I didn't really a trusted
engine there but I need to find it now
myself a hit 95 and Kings it to some
something like that will ultimately be
be a zoosk fun but I'm not quite sure
yet hmm how does this really work there
should be some how do you win exactly
9f to King see 293 how do your windows
exactly I have to do the move somehow I
go all the way back here check this is
winning check one there should be three
mm-hmm now that can be tricky sorry for
that live analysis I'm just a bit unsure
how does the told us that actually win
this is what he played but how does
black win after 93 okay I'm going I'm
going to look at the game and see what
happens they're here and then check
afterwards not completely sure what song
is actually getting to right now King
here night f2 right d 3 we had the swine
yeah okay okay okay bishop in 39 f 2
yeah this this is this one yeah that's
clear you just have to do the tempo down
so i need to get get to this position
means that let's check it again we need
this position so we need the king on c3
and the bishop on d6 this is the zooks
long position so probably we will go
with a king first here and what now
bishop f
probably is because now this is this is
a super swollen yeah okay that is the
point so 93 is not working and wash
axiom we go here here and again we we
got the soup spark here we will win
apart okay so it will ultimately be this
pollution so in the game Nyjah for I
know how Detroit f5 takes Jinxy to and
now this is promoting white cannot stop
that so the world champion lost this
game again signs on degree shock um a
bit about some strange things about the
game have I didn t like the opening
position when he really very clearly and
yeah aimed for it yeah with the with
this choice of his choice of opening the
real mystery is the move g-form that
around here okay the position is is very
equal here and if white plays something
normal and look the one or whatever
something that probably should prevent
Bishop before so whoopty one makes quite
some sense nothing happens nothing
happens simply and after me here like is
really in control we are always having
that pressure on f2 and the chance is to
take here and pick up their pawn it was
not really good ok the next game and
final game for that coverage is a Kimura
aronia let's see what happened here
wait and Aronian is going from his
favorite Marshall attack Nakamura is
avoiding that by playing a four and now
be four was played g-46 takes takes
takes on the 8th route 8 yeah this line
has featured heavily in ronnians games
he's playing that a 4 before exactly
that line he's playing that all of the
time if they go a 4 against his martial
and so it was clearly part of Nakamura's
preparation and the general unbelievers
that this doesn't give wide much and
warm n not much not a nothing at all and
this game is not really shaking this the
successor this assessment I'm sorry um
it's quite a mystery what Nakamura was
exactly planning and we see now that he
regrouped his Bishop to c4 and went a
five mukhi eight Bishop d3 this position
yeah what is why playing for I really
don't know I mean black can play the
night over to c5 and he can maybe do
something against a five pawn and I
really don't like transposition have to
admit it looks kind of I mean why does
certainly solid but like Amber some goal
in that game certainly was to win trying
to win and get to play for the win in
this event mean Aronian is leading the
tournament and my camera I've just had
this great win against Lester sauce or
something had something to build upon so
he definitely wanted to wanted to win
and well this is not really I mean it's
not really clear what wine is doing in
this position
he is solid but he's really not having
any kind of claim for an advantage this
square looks nicer that it was neglected
by the push of the B porn but we
shouldn't forget that in the same um
procedure black also has gained the c5
square this is also not controlled by
white so it's not that this is a
one-sided term yeah trade-off of squares
it's not just white getting see forward
leg also has gotten see file for this
and he can't take that pawn we see that
aronian is regrouping that nicely night
over to c5 and he had one of his eyes
shine gets going you can always call the
trademark maneuver they look to the
fifth he has played that quite a bit in
the in the willow pass his handling of
rooks is always always interesting and
an interesting little fact here or part
of this disposition is that black on
paper if you do it by a classical
standards that was wrong in wrong carol
has a terrible bishop yeah or Peter all
pawns are on dark square and this Bishop
is on dark squares as well well White's
bishop is fitting with the pawns nicely
still White's bishop is not doing
anything it's looking at that e5 pawn
which is very safely defended and blacks
bishop isn't a real issue because it can
be activated and this is in fact um
aronian some next step in this pollution
yeah he went over here attacking a five
so wyd has to use now to looks to keep
that part it's not exactly ideal Bishop
c5 improvement of the look
and now it gets traded the interesting
effect is with the bishop gone black all
of a sudden has the opportunity to use
the default square for its night very
nice yeah so now I'm after night FK exam
III um there were a couple of options
black also could have a took only three
I am sorry he took only three he also
could have taken on b2 and after let's
say a rook takes probably continuum to
play from this position I yes is this
nice square here that also was
interesting not a bad choice at all
however he took on e3 I think the idea
is that the bishop is still a very solid
piece here and the nights I just found
one and effective in this in this type
of position centralizing first analogy
for I'm not sure about that wolf it
seems more weakening them then then
really leading to much I mean f4 is a
pretty glaring weakness and I didn't
really see the positive side of the moon
in general only black can do something
and aronia played it very very very
nicely slowly getting forward
yeah the ideal night formation their
check here we go and Nigel yeah we see
that g4 I don't know it did really
didn't seem to help antiques the black
is better at this position and it's
pretty clear that he has all the ideas
but it is not entirely clear if he's
really having a decisive advantage we
see that a couple of moves later here
now Nakamura planes the move rook t1 and
after that he's really in deep trouble
it seems he probably should have tried
rook f1 lending I'm sorry I'm pretty
clicking badly I'm lending extra
protection to that point yeah currently
if black takes here you get far too much
play for that so that's that's not
working this after Luke f8 starts to get
ugly so the f3 porn look sir yeah
indefensible and he now takes only 5
yeah what else if he does that like will
take and there is no compensation really
yeah 95 was tried by Nakamura check it
now black is crashing through it is
relatively easy to play I can give a ton
of checks chan chan repeating a little
bit and now taking on h2 yeah Black now
has extra pawns I was one at the moment
another five it's one part but the
remaining points and all week yeah and
in addition I mean blacks king is in the
middle of the board and whites it's just
totally passive yeah check him up to
four
and that was falling and after Luke's is
Linda camera resigned yeah so lots here
for the currently going to live readings
world number two here I come Nakamura
yeah and aronian really having a great
event is on plus three years beaten all
the American players Caruana so
Antonella camera quite quite funny
Howard sometimes sometimes goes yeah in
that game the cameras opening choice
doesn't feel very inspiring I mean this
is part of this is what he had prepared
it seems and wide really has absolutely
nothing and Aronian also has a great
experience in that position time we saw
that he was really absolutely never
close to being in some kind of trouble
it was was very smooth sailing basically
and all in all um it's quite mysterious
what turned you drew nakamura to play
this it's however not so easy if we
chose again to determine what went wrong
obviously that rook 81 move for giving
up f3 at the end was awesome a big a big
mistake but he really was in deep
trouble beforehand but it's hard to
pinpoint the exact moment there i mean i
think around here it's not helping and I
don't really like g4 I do I don't see
the point of that really what it is what
it is doing but it is definitely already
very uncomfortable because black has all
the all the ideas and white can't
basically just sit and wait he has a
very unattractive position so what does
that mean after this round it means that
Aronian is leading alone one
the head of the field a couple of
players are behind with 11 points
trailing by one point so he has
excellent chances to win that event
which would be I think yeah good sign
after his very bad year that he had on
that he gets against a tournament
winning it's not done yet there's still
two rounds to play but his chance of
course excellent yeah I hope you enjoyed
that overview of round seven and I'll be
back tomorrow with round eight recap
thanks for watching